we interviewed a gentleman who said that
a lot of hollywood work is like
temp work you're kind of swinging from
one job to another
and it's never where you're really
landing in one spot
yeah but on the flip side you could say
well there's a lot of people that had
corporate jobs that
they were just given a severance package
and
pushed out the door yeah so nothing is
really guaranteed
absolutely yeah no it's it's it's true i
mean
i think the nature of
most film work or at least the film work
that i do
um is there just isn't stability
they're just and there won't be you know
i i remember
years ago this would have been this was
probably 20 years ago
i saw an interview with kevin bacon and
he was
is still i believe married to kira
sedgwick and
it was them and kevin bacon you know has
been around since i was a kid
and he said that after every project
when it goes quiet he gets very nervous
he's like oh no am i ever gonna work
again.
and i remember that sticking out to me
like wait kevin bacon
is worried about getting work and
now that i've been in the industry for a
little while oh right
like there's just no you have no idea
if you will be even if you're on top of
the world
two years from now you know maybe nobody
remembers your name
or you shoot a project that bombs or you
know whatever it is
it's it's such a competitive world
and i think you know i i
i don't think it's a good industry to
base your life on if you want to build a
healthy family and i hate saying that
because it is an industry i love so
dearly
but having a relationship
when you're gone you know 80 hours a
week and you come home you're exhausted
uh i don't know you you have to have a
special partnership to make that work i
think it's very
uh stressful on all your relationships
romantic friend all that
and i you know i don't know
i mean i think mostly i like to
put that out there it doesn't nothing is
good or bad it just is
you know like and that's just a fact of
our industry and i think it's important
for people to
realize that because it's i think there
are a lot of romantic ideas going in
but the reality of it is and especially
now you know i don't know
will movie theaters open back up period
i'm sure they're going to open up in
some capacity but
you know our world is changing and
streaming
is now huge i mean there are more tv
shows being made than ever in the
history
of of hollywood
but there are no more residuals you know
almost entirely gone
and that's how a lot of writers and
directors and actors maintained a career
is that you were getting residuals from
old projects but they don't
have residuals on any of the streaming
services
so the future of our industry is very
uncertain
but the flip side is is if you if you
just look at the
the art of making and you know between
youtube and all these shows on netflix
and hulu and amazon and all these
there's more work and creation
being done than ever before it's just
the money is the trick
but money's always the trick i suppose
sure
but when you look at your imdb and just
your your body of work
it would be you know i'm surprised to
hear you question that but i think
that's a healthy
questioning though just being realistic
yeah yeah i mean i think i think that's
part is not taking it for granted
and not never assuming that the future
is going to be what the present is
because it probably won't be
and you know i've shot i've only ever
shot
one project that anyone has heard of
and and that so
i think i've shot 10
[Music]
seasons of tv and one
got you know it was a hit to some
capacity at least for its size
nobody's ever heard of the features i
shot like it's
you never know what's going to go in
what direction and so for me
it's really important that i love the
work the craft which i do
because you have no control over the
other elements of it
and so i try to when i when i can
pay attention to who am i working with
the people make a real difference just
in terms of quality of life day to day
but yeah i mean
you never know what's gonna work or
what's not gonna work or what anybody
will find i've shot
i shot i don't remember now four or five
series for um go 90 which was a verizon
streaming service which
doesn't exist anymore so even even the
full streaming service the the channel
just ceased to exist
let alone those shows but i loved the
work and i'm proud of the work we did on
a lot of those shows i really i hope
they find themselves at home
because some of them are really good
shows
but again i have no control over that
and so learning to let go helps
is you just control what you can which
is on set
on the day you do as good a job as you
can
be pleasant to work with enjoy it
because that's
you know that's still your life day to
day there
so yeah it's weird it's very it's very
strange it's it's
depressing when i think about the
realities of the industry
i tend to get pretty discouraged you
know i because i would like to
i would like to put some roots down buy
a house one day or
whatever that might look like and
i don't know when or if or how that'll
go
so yeah but for now i still love the
work like i get
excited i just read a script this week
for a feature that may or may not happen
and uh in the new year and it's like oh
yeah
how would i shoot this shot and who how
what's the look of this
i still get really excited about that so
i let i let that
lead me but you know i'm in my 40s so
you are
okay i i did not know that i thought you
were much younger okay yeah
no it's yeah it's the year you're
sleeping
yeah sleeping well it's a pandemic okay
well i gotta give you that
i'm sure there's other folks out there
that are in a similar boat they're
looking for work they're ready for work
but it's not there or whatever the case
may be
how do you keep yourself in check you
said you have a meditation practice
yeah i mean so i know myself well enough
at this point
and i'm still learning i've figured out
all my quirks but
i know that if i don't go for walks i
will start to go crazy
um going to the movie theater has always
been a big thing for me i always feel
very um at peace in a movie theater but
that is not an option these days so
trying to i've not gotten myself out to
nature often enough
but i know that that usually a few days
of camping
will usually kind of reset me
but how i eat and making sure there's
some exercise in my life
and i almost take it like medicine it
has nothing to do with
oh today's a good day to exercise or i
feel like exercising
no no no like i have to because i will
lose my mind otherwise
and so a part of it is really just
being able to have the discipline i
guess
which is for me feels strange to say
because i don't think of myself as a
disciplined person but
for anything that anything regarding
filmmaking i've always been able to
convince myself
to do something for the greater good so
keeping myself healthy
for my own life maybe doesn't work but
to keep myself healthy
so that i'm a better filmmaker so that
hour 13
i'm still energetic that's somehow
always been
able been a way that i've been able to
keep myself
you know happy and healthy to some
degree
and i've always struggled with anxiety
and so i have these
little things that i just know i need to
do or
you know i could lose a handle and who
knows just go crazy
so here's johnny here's johnny exactly
no i mean i mean i make light of it but
i think a lot of
we're all there in somewhere and because
this is uncharted territory
and and we thought we'd seen the worst
with the great recession and then
there's so many aspects that we're just
you know this is you know
been a very trying year in so many ways
for sure yeah
yeah and i will say i mean
gratitude is a big that's something i'm
really trying to practice is
just being thankful for i mean the fact
that i shot a show that found an
audience and that people like i'm so
grateful for that after
years of just grinding and you know it
felt like i was banging my head against
a wall and then
like oh people like this that's great
and it feels good but it's also
like that's already gone and so just to
be grateful
that something like that grateful for my
health you know
anything that you can be grateful for i
think goes a long way i think it's easy
to to spiral in a global pandemic
in a country that is uh you know pretty
divided and a lot of anger and
frustration
i think i don't you know it's dangerous
you don't want to ignore
anything but is finding the things that
make you
bring you some sort of peace and even
joy i think is so
important remember why you know
why do you want to live this life like
why oh yeah right
like hugging i remember hugging
hugging's pretty good i'm assuming we'll
do that again one day
so there's just yeah trying to be
grateful for
as much as you can and you know when i
moved into my new house
i bought myself a really nice tv and i
was like oh this is really expensive i
don't know if i should
but i did knowing that i had a show
coming and i was like okay i can
rationalize the cost
but now in the pandemic i love that i
have this huge
tv and i'm watching you know all manner
of things and
it's a nice little treat and i can't go
to a movie theater
but i have a nice setup at home which i
didn't have forever so
you know i'm thankful for that gratitude
i think is a good
a good tool hard to exercise but yeah
what's your favorite thing to watch on
this new tv now oh
man you know what i've been really i
mean i'm all over the place but
i have i love watching a movie from like
the 70s or 80s where it has this like
beautiful film grain and i love
watching the grain because my the tv is
really nice
and the uh the blacks like go really
black so
if you watch somebody like gordon willis
you know a legendary cinematographer
his work he really leaned into
people called him the prince of darkness
and you watch these images that are
really dark but they have this grain
dancing through it film
grain is such a i have such a like a
romantic
nostalgic reaction to it so it makes me
really happy to watch films with a ton
of grain
dirt it's it's funny i have this clean
tv and my favorite things
are the dirty images i love those
yeah that's awesome now i love sometimes
watching 90s
80s talk shows i mean i love phil
donahue
jenny jones there's just something
you can't i don't know there's something
very romantic about i know it sounds
yeah
but there is nostalgic this like you
know phil donahue and the hairstyles and
totally yeah yeah nostalgia is a
superpower
you